[Music]
i was driving the other day with cash
and i was thinking
about how
i would maybe try to get out of a
speeding ticket
how'd you do it so like you're the cop
okay
do you know how fast you're going sir
officer just before we continue just do
me a favor mm-hmm just close your eyes
uh okay so this is not really protocol
just trust me just trust me just close
your eyes okay
all right now ask it again
do you know how fast you're going
i'm not sure
oh
oh
you sound like my favorite uh twitch
streamer
oh yeah
his name is noel miller
i was just thinking what if you
just try to get the whole ticket just
you really put it out there like tell me
how fast i was going like trying to do
the tick tock guy girl voice yeah yeah
drop it all the way to your stomach
are you gonna take me away
it's like why don't you put the ticket
between my big jugs
i have huge tits wait you do
massive double teams i'm picturing them
right now
oh my god
oh
huge milkies i'm scared you're gonna see
into my big milkies if you open your
eyes oh i won't i won't i won't open my
eyes
damn it foiled again
this is officer dinklebob
this the horniest officer